I tried assigning new kanji to famous places:
Texas, the great state of all things, New York, eternal sleeplessness, the city of Berlin, the
city of attack,
Australia, the land of deadly poisonous animals, New Zealand, the magical island, the United Kingdom's gifted
friend country, Rio de Janeiro, no, it's a
little different, but there's an arrow
in Rio, Los Angeles, multiple angels, and
no Las Pegas.  Cities or Muyo cities Montana
Humanity Bushu Niseko Town Domestic and overseas Nagoya
Shino City Osaka Kogo Or rather Osaka is almost
flat Hokkaido Ushiojima Honshu Fushu Shikoku To be more precise,
exam Kyushu Excellent Eastern country rather than China
Hong Kong Former Hong Kong Vatican  Top secret small country Cupertino
Apple birth city Helsinki Sun Extreme City
Amsterdam Super large white man or bicycle heaven Singapore
Half fish half dead country Large public and private country Half way peninsula
Japan Yoyo or Logistic America
United States Japan From Japan, it has just
hit home or America
Education
Country